[Musica]
[Applauso]
buon pomeriggio
molti di voi si chiederanno che
c'azzecca l'agricoltura e la produzione
di alimenti con l'esplorazione spaziale
tutto nasce da un editoriale pubblicato
sul network o lo gen evolution lo scorso
anno in questo editoriale si sosteneva
che l'agricoltura non ha bisogno di
soluzioni hi tech e che soluzioni low
tech sono altrettanto importanti così
come lo sono state per la pandemia da
covi 19 forse dimenticandosi che se oggi
siamo tutti qui assieme e se l'impatto
della pandemia non è più così devastante
come era lo era agli inizi questo e
grazie a una soluzione estremamente hi
tech come sono i vaccini mrna
quello che voglio fare nei prossimi
minuti assieme a voi è
discutere tre cose qual è l'impatto
sull'ambiente della produzione di
alimenti quali sono le soluzioni che
possiamo utilizzare per diminuire questo
impatto e infine quali sono gli ostacoli
che si frappongono all'adozione di
queste soluzioni
partiamo da una semplice constatazione
noi oggi stiamo utilizzando le risorse
naturali del nostro pianeta in maniera
non sostenibile ossia stiamo consumando
più risorse naturali di quanto queste
risorse non siano capaci di
autorigenerarsi ciò dimostra in maniera
formale l'equazione dell'impatto globale
che mette a confronto le impronta
ecologica delle attività umane e la
capacità rigenerativa della biosfera
oggi questa impronta ecologica è pari a
circa 1,6 volte la capacità della
biosfera di rigenerarsi
cosa vuol dire questo vuol dire che
stiamo intaccando pesantemente
il capitale di risorse naturali e che se
continuiamo a farlo è più continuiamo a
farlo più questa disuguaglianza tenderà
ad aumentare
come possiamo fare per cercare di
portare questa equazione in una
situazione di uguaglianza in quell
impronta ecologica è almeno pari alla
capacità rigenerativa
se guardate il termine a sinistra
dell'equazione è difficile pensare di
agire sul fattore enne che la dimensione
della popolazione globale è altrettanto
difficile pensare di agire sul fattore y
che è la nostra capacità di produrre
beni e servizi cioè ricchezza perché
sarebbe una scelta molto impopolare
possiamo agire sul fattore alfa che sta
al denominatore il fattore alfa
corrisponde all'efficienza con cui
sfruttiamo le risorse naturali
efficienza vuol dire scelte politiche e
vuol dire soprattutto innovazione
tecnologica
al contrario di quello che tendiamo a
pensare
produrre cibo per alimentarci è uno dei
processi più costosi dal punto di vista
ambientale
noi tendiamo ingenera pensare ad altri
processi ad altre attività economiche
come quelle più impattanti sull'ambiente
le analisi ci dicono che il 34 per cento
di tutte le emissioni di gas serra sono
dovute alla produzione di alimenti e di
questo 34 per cento il 71 per cento è
dovuta alle attività di produzione
primaria cioè alle sole attività
agricole
tutti i processi che stanno a valle i
processi di trasformazione pesano solo
per il restante 29 per cento non sono
solo le attività agricole in sé a pesare
sono anche i cosiddetti cambiamenti di
uso del suolo ossia il fatto che per
produrre alimenti
cambiamo la destinazione dei suoli che
erano occupati dai co sistemi naturali e
li convertiamo in
terreni agricoli
non solo la produzione di alimenti
impatta molto sull'ambiente ma le
analisi di sensibilità effettuate dagli
economisti ci mostrano anche che
produzione di cibo scelte della dieta e
politiche di uso del suolo sono i
fattori agendo sui quali possiamo più
facilmente andare a ridurre l'impatto
ambientale delle attività umane
questo non è una cosa intuitiva perché
noi tendiamo a pensare ad altri settori
come quelli dove dovremmo agire se
vogliamo migliorare la nostra impronta
ecologica pensiamo a efficientamento
energetico degli edifici pensiamo a uso
di carburanti fossili pensiamo alle
attività manifatturiere in realtà e
agendo sull'agricoltura che potremo più
facilmente riuscire a migliorare la
situazione voglio farvi un esempio di
come è cambiato l'uso del suolo nel
corso del tempo in questo grafico vedete
quello che è successo negli ultimi 300
anni quello che si vede molto facilmente
è che sono diminuite le aree occupate da
foreste occupate da praterie da savane
cioè dai co sistemi naturali e sono
aumentate le aree occupate da terreni
agricoli e pascoli per darvi alcuni
numeri ad essere più precisi
vi basti pensare che dal 1980 al 2000
nei paesi tropicali che sono quelli più
ricchi di biodiversità più ricchi di
ecosistemi che dobbiamo a tutti i costi
difendere le superfici agricole sono
aumentate di oltre 100 milioni di ettari
cioè una superficie superiore a tre
volte quella dell'italia
basti pensare che per alimentare gli
animali domestici che a tutti noi stanno
così cari viene utilizzato l'uno per
cento della superficie agricola mondiale
che pari a 1,6 volte la superficie
dell'italia
oppure che i soli allevamenti animali
utilizzano il 77 per cento della
superficie agricola mondiale
se poi vogliamo vedere gli impatti della
produzione di alimenti sulla fauna
vi basti pensare che l'uomo e mammiferi
che vengono usati per l'allevamento
animale assommano al 96 per cento della
massa di tutti i mammiferi presenti sul
pianeta e che se guardiamo gli uccelli
il 70 per cento degli uccelli presenti
sul pianeta sono volatili d'allevamento
voglio adesso
spiegarvi come la produzione di cibo
impatta dando un esempio molto concreto
e molto vicino a noi cioè discutere qual
è l'impatto ambientale globale della
produzione di un filone di pane
quando facciamo questo tipo di analisi
consideriamo l'impatto a partire dal
momento in cui vengono seminati semi di
frumento fino al momento in cui il
filone di pane arriva sulle nostre
tavole ebbene qualsiasi sia l'indicatore
di impatto che noi utilizziamo e
guardiano circa due terzi dell'impatto
della produzione di pane sono dovuti
alla sola produzione primaria cioè dal
momento in cui seminiamo al momento in
cui raccogliamo solo un terzo e tutto
quello che viene dopo
trasformazione catena di distribuzione
trasporto fra l'altro per i fanatici del
chilometro zero al trasporto pesa
estremamente poco
di questi due terzi di impatto dovuto
alla produzione agricola a loro volta
due terzi cioè il 45 per cento
dell'impatto globale è dovuto a un unico
fattore e questa è la fertilizzazione
azotata
analisi di questo tipo sono estremamente
importanti perché abbiamo bisogno di
sapere quali sono i fattori che
impattano di più perché andando ad agire
su quei fattori che possiamo più
facilmente diminuire l'impatto
ambientale della produzione di alimenti
ora è evidente da quello che vi ho
raccontato finora che noi dobbiamo
riuscire a rendere più efficiente la
produzione primaria dobbiamo cioè
migliorare quel coefficiente alfa di cui
abbiamo parlato prima per la produzione
primaria e questo lo possiamo fare
attraverso l'innovazione tecnologica
volendo essere molto schematici in
agricoltura ci sono tre maniere per
portare innovazione una e attraverso la
genetica attraverso il miglioramento
genetico andando a modificare
geneticamente
le piante animali che utilizziamo per
alimentarci lo stiamo facendo da 10.000
anni e l'abbiamo fatto nel corso del
tempo con metodi via via più efficienti
e veloci
l'altra strada è la chimica cioè
attraverso l'utilizzo di fertilizzanti
di agrofarmaci di erbicidi e infine la
terza strada è rappresentata dalle
tecniche agronomiche ora al dato storico
ci dice che di questi tre fattori quello
che ha aumentato di piu produttivita e
sostenibilità dell'agricoltura è proprio
la genetica il miglioramento genetico
è l'esempio migliore è dato dall
adozione degli ibridi di mais
a partire dal 1930 quando furono
adottati per la prima volta grazie al
ibridi di mais la resa produttiva del
mais è aumentata di oltre cinque volte
oggi abbiamo per il miglioramento
genetico a disposizione nuovi strumenti
che lo rendono ancora più preciso e
veloce
questi nuovi strumenti ci sono forniti
da un lato dagli avanzamenti tumultuosi
della genomica che ha consentito non
solo di sequenziare il nostro genoma ma
anche di sequenziare i genomi di molte
specie di interesse agricolo di
identificare tutti i geni presenti al
loro interno e fra questi di
identificare quelli che controllano le
caratteristiche che hanno interesse a
migliorare
dall'altro dalla messa a punto di
tecnologie che in italia chiamiamo
collettivamente tecnologie di evoluzione
assistita o tea come la cisl genesi o
come soprattutto il gino made it in
tramite chris per cars che ci consente
di andare a modificare in maniera mirata
singoli geni o singole basi addirittura
all'interno di questi geni ottenendo dei
risultati che sono pressoché
indistinguibili da quelli che potremmo
ottenere per incrocio o che si
potrebbero ottenere permutazione
spontanea e utilizzando queste
tecnologie
noi possiamo
cercare di andare a migliorare la
resistenza ai patogeni di andare a
migliorare la tolleranza la siccità di
andare a migliorare l'efficienza d'uso
dei fertilizzanti di andare a migliorare
l'efficienza di utilizzo della
radiazione solare nel processo
fotosintetico
grazie a ciò potremmo
conciliare una maggiore sostenibilità
senza dover diminuire la produttività
non è la genetica l'unica strada per
portare innovazione in agricoltura
l'altra tecnologia che porterà una vera
rivoluzione in campo agricolo e la
cosiddetta agricoltura digitale di
precisione la quale attraverso
l'utilizzo di una serie di tecniche
agronomiche che si basano
sull'innovazione digitale ci consentirà
di meglio utilizzare i fattori
produttivi come acqua come fertilizzanti
e come agrofarmaci
ora se queste sono le soluzioni
quello che ci dobbiamo chiedere e quali
sono attualmente gli ostacoli che si
frappongono al d'azione di queste
soluzioni e gli ostacoli non sono oggi
di natura scientifica non sono neppure
legate al processo di trasferimento
tecnologico sono principalmente ostacoli
di tipo sociale
tradizionalmente la storia ci insegna
che l'uomo è sempre stato refrattario
all'introduzione di innovazioni
tecnologiche se questo è stato vero nel
corso della storia è ancora più vero
oggi quando si parla di alimentazione e
di agricoltura perché i consumatori
quando si parla di alimentazione
agricoltura oggi sembrano molto più
interessati a guardare indietro
piuttosto che a guardare in avanti e se
non avevano la nostalgia per un passato
che in realtà era molto meno roseo di
quanto non si voglia ammettere
un'alimentazione adeguata in un passato
non troppo lontano era un lusso per
pochi
eppure oggi le scelte del consumatore
vengono principalmente dettate da
criteri quali naturale tradizionale
piccolo è bello e via dicendo
questa nostalgia per il passato è
pericolosa perché se vogliamo tornare a
fare quello che facevano in passato
potremmo forse aumentare la
sostenibilità per unità di superficie ma
sicuramente diminuiremo la produttività
e diminuiremo la sostenibilità se la
misuriamo per unità di prodotto e
finiremo con il far produrre altri
quello che non vogliamo più produrre noi
questa sarebbe ad esempio una delle
conseguenze di una adozione su scala
globale dell'agricoltura biologica la
quale avendo al momento rese produttive
sensibilmente inferiore all'agricoltura
tradizionale
comporterebbe un aumento delle superfici
coltivate dal 40 al 65 per cento
fatto questo che certamente non ci
possiamo permettere perché vorrebbe dire
distruggere ecosistemi naturali e
minacciare l'esistenza stessa della
biodiversità presente sul nostro pianeta
ma
anche se queste scelte non venissero
fatte su scala globale venissero fatto
su scala locale come potrebbe ad esempio
fare l'unione europea che potrebbe
decidere che
accetta una diminuzione di produzione in
cambio di un aumento di sostenibilità
dicevo queste scelte non sono scevre da
impatti sugli altri perché se quello che
non produciamo più e noi lo facciamo
produrre ad altri
finisce che saranno questi altri a
pagare il prezzo e sarà il pianeta
pagare un prezzo globalmente più elevato
se questi a cui facciamo produrre le
cose che non produciamo più noi lo fanno
in maniera meno efficiente di quanto non
lo potremmo fare noi
è un'ingiustizia profonda che si va a
sommare alle tante ingiustizie e
disuguaglianze che sono presente del
nostro pianeta già oggi come si vede da
questo grafico i paesi più ricchi dove
si concentrano i consumi in realtà
stanno sfruttando le risorse naturali
dei paesi più poveri che sono fra
l'altro quelli più ricchi di risorse
naturali stanno intaccando il loro
capitale dei risorse naturali senza in
alcun modo ricompensarli per il fatto di
avere rovinato il loro patrimonio
naturale con le nostre scelte in campo
di politica agricola noi rischiamo di
peggiorare ancora la situazione perché
se quello che non coltiviamo noi lo
dovranno coltivare i paesi dell'africa
dell'america latina dove si concentra la
biodiversità noi andremo a minacciare le
loro risorse naturali che costituiscono
il loro patrimonio più prezioso ma che
sono anche un patrimonio molto prezioso
per tutto il pianeta
ora venendo a chiudere
cosa possiamo fare per cercare di
cambiare la situazione e cercare di
convincere i consumatori che
l'innovazione in agricoltura serve ed è
un fatto positivo
dobbiamo spiegare che l'innovazione
tecnologica e la scienza ci possono
permettere di far stare assieme termini
che sembrano antitetici ci possono
permettere di combinare produttività e
sostenibilità si possono permettere di
conciliare innovazione tradizione ci
possono permettere di conciliare
innovazione e diversificazione agricola
ed alimentare e ci possono aiutare a
ridurre quelle diseguaglianze economiche
e sociali che sono un problema enorme
del nostro pianeta che si assomma al
cambiamento climatico alla perdita di
biodiversità
abbiamo bisogno di un approccio
flessibile non dobbiamo essere dogmatici
dobbiamo stabilire un nuovo patto basato
sulla fiducia reciproca fra scienziati
agricoltori e consumatori
spero con questo breve discorso di
averli convinti che l'agricoltura è
molto più complessa della rocket science
è un problema complesso che richiede una
soluzione molto complessa e in questa
soluzione un ruolo decisivo hanno le
nostre scelte individuali che devono
essere dettate da razionalità e scienza
non da
emotività e ideologia facciamo scelte
logiche e non ideologiche per cercare di
salvare il nostro pianeta
[Applauso]